north korean leader kim jong-un has
warned he is ready to use nuclear
weapons against rivals the united states
and south korea the warning came as
north koreans marked the 69th
anniversary of the armistice that ended
hostilities in the korean war this day
is known as victory day in north korea
kim's warnings come amid fears his
country is preparing to conduct a
seventh nuclear test analysts see his
latest rhetoric as an attempt to shore
up morale in a country dealing with a
covet outbreak
a faltering economy and the threat of
renewed sanctions but the celebrations
on wednesday provided no hint of any
such troubles
at pyongyang's kim il-sung square
citizens dance to mark the so-called
victory day
although the korean war in the 50s ended
in a truce for north korea it was a
victory against the u.s
nationwide celebrations already started
much earlier in the day
filling the streets with pride
we're marching towards the victorious
fatherland liberation war museum while
singing songs that the war victors used
to sing
in a speech to mark the event north
korean leader kim jong-un claimed the
country is ready for military clashes
with the u.s
this came as washington said pyongyang
could conduct a nuclear test anytime the
first since 2017.
kim said our armed forces are thoroughly
prepared to respond to any crisis and
our state's nuclear war deterrence is
also fully ready to mobilize its
absolute strength faithfully accurately
and promptly to its mission
while north korean rhetoric is often
fiery tensions have in fact been rising
on the peninsula
south korean president yun seokyo has
laid out a more aggressive defense
policy since he took office in may
it would allow seoul to launch
preemptive strikes on certain targets
which could kill kim jong-un himself
the government also warned of
consequences if the north conducts a
nuclear test
[Music]
north korea would face even stronger
sanctions if it pushes ahead with the
seventh nuclear test
a hawkish stance kim jong-un strongly
despised
on the victory day he criticized the
south korean president and branded his
administration quote a group of
gangsters
[Laughter]
but for most north koreans it wasn't a
day of fury it simply was an event of
joy pride and a lot of entertainment